hey guys it's Justine and we are not in
my kitchen
we are actually in chef Riley's kitchen
here at the Pizza Hut headquarters and
we are going to make an official
iJustine thing so that you guys can
order at home why are we here because
you guys are watching something really
awesome we're about to introduce you to
an all-new flavor of now menu to the
point where you can build two billion
combinations and flavors and recipes now
that's big and you're gonna watch me
make it here and I'm gonna happen any
time any time these guys that don't know
I can't go so let's start in the bottle
bring the bowl over let's grab a ladle
I'll let you away all but your favorite
amount on top do I have to use the ladle
I would suggest no this isn't if I was
at home I would have just taken as a
floppy
people right down the middle if you want
or have some fun with it there you go
dollops get a little smile except a
little bit more okay I do like a lot of
sauce sauce is good kind of the same as
a little bit of space on the edge I'm
afraid I'm gonna just doing great okay
you're doing great I'm liking what
you're doing with this hand yeah this is
good okay look at this I think I'm
satisfied with my amount of blending I
will get rid of that okay I know you
like cheese now you love have I do a fun
little sprinkling how am i doing so far
I just need methanol big enough you can
use it any time Pat finding that is more
just making Georg I feel like invite you
hold up really high it just gives me a
nice advantage point all right this is
good making pizza guy do some more oh
really
think of it Oh an hour yeah we're
cooking oh my gosh I'm so pumped up
about this
shimmy shimmy shhh okay
I'm gonna just be a little more precise
well you go into my virtual people are
closer Leah I'm there already
oh my that's true you're like I'm here
in real life I think I should with a
pepperoni first all right let's do it
okay so some of you may be like just see
and I thought you didn't eat meat well
guess what I had a cheeseburger not too
long ago and I now have no longer a
vegetarian how am i doing you're doing
great good enough I'm pretty good I
think so I have a like your placement I
love pepperonis too so so now what else
do you think would be an absolute wind
room in Ruby endeavors mobium peppers
they're real sweet yes I am I'm gonna
even them out a little bit okay I'd like
to flip them all over now are you sure
that's enough that's it
[Music]
Wow
and again they taste better when you
juggle them oh my gosh I've never
juggled meatballs before but I'm really
glad that's amazing we have something in
common me either
well I mean if you want to hop in no
okay all right I don't know all around
the u.s. all these uh pizzahut chefs are
gonna be like that we are not going to
sit there and make a J out of these
meatballs these are banana peppers and
there is so good they're very very good
well let's just put a couple of those on
and if somebody's like you know what
Justine I deliver Nana peppers on my I J
pizza you can say hold with banana
peppers now that's magic all right
where's the other night and the village
[Music]
so our pizza just came out of the oven
and now we're gonna be coming up with
new crust flavor and after trying all of
the ones in the kitchen I wanted the hot
favorite yeah basically we just would
paint we paint brush how's that and I
just see what around the edge here ice
don't Baker go home love it love it
looks great now choose your weapon we
can I put a drizzle you want to treasure
hazel okay I've been doing balsamic all
right let's get these out of your way
I'm gonna make an IJ but the proper
pizza hot way is obviously getting it
something gets all over your pizza
[Applause]
that just happened it looks really good
losing my mind this is amazing that's
gonna get really good all right ready
cut do you wanna cut no oh God wait you
can cut are you guys like me in the
right direction it doesn t those matter
you ready just chop it up because this
is your artwork I didn't want to ruin it
okay here we go
tears sing pick you guys ready um now
that the crust is flavored I'm just into
the crust right hurry to pick my meat
off did it go really good
mind you the taste test in my kitchen
thank you
never turns off as well alright guys up
thanks for watching sorry a trouble my
mouth will let me know if you guys
already got too soon piece of please
send me in this room send me a piece of
selfie have a pizza party I'm speechless
right now
good I'm a delight I've got a lot of
good days but this is definitely like
I'm so good top number one in top number
one and top number one it's good food
thanks guys I love you I'll see you soon
I'm so happy I'm so happy I don't even
get such a crust yet this is the final
official I just need Pizza Hut pizza I'm
so excited I am basically creating this
with my own two hands although they
actually professionally created this one
with their own two hands to make it
looks like what you guys will get at
home
this is it it's official there's not
going to be an IG on it because they
wanted to make sure that the meatballs
actually covered the entire pizza let's
order one make sure you guys take a
picture tweet it to me Instagram it to
me I'll be liking all of those photos
and retweeting make sure you guys use
the hashtag IG pizza and hash tag flavor
of now enjoy your pizza have a party and
I need my friends back and there's a
really good job so really good a good
job you guys professional lies didn't
mean it look like actually really good